my name is Caitlin I'm a senior majoring
in American Studies I have the pleasure
of introducing our speaker tonight Jeff
Shepherd he is an author and lawyer and
he earned his BA from Whittier College
and his JD from Harvard Law School in
1969 he was selected to be a White House
Fellow and assigned to the Treasury
Department where he worked under Paul
Volcker the undersecretary for Monetary
Affairs he then joined the John
Ehrlichman s domestic council staff at
the Nixon White House where he served
for five years he also worked on
President Nixon's Watergate defense team
where he was principal deputy to the
president's lead lawyer J Fred Buzzard
in that capacity he helped transcribe
the White House tapes and ran the
document rooms holding the seized files
of H R Haldeman John Ehrlichman and John
Dean mr. Shepard is the author of the
real Watergate scandal collusion
conspiracy and the plot that brought
Nixon down please join me in welcoming
Jeff Shepard
[Applause]
I've been I came out on Sunday morning
and I heard the previous three speakers
and after each speaker I went back and
changed my presentation so we don't know
what I think until you hear what I say
so but I've really enjoyed my time this
is my first time to Hillsdale but I feel
I feel very welcomed welcoming and it's
it's like I've been here before but let
me tell you why because the college I
went to is very similar the Hillsdale a
small liberal arts college 1,500 people
located in a rural area founded by a
religious sect that was big on education
and really against slavery and that of
course is Whittier College dick Nixon
went to Whittier so did I and John
Greenleaf Whittier in case he was among
the most popular poets in the nineteenth
century but you picture him as this old
man with a beard who wrote a twenty nine
page poem about snow in New Hampshire
but when when Whittier was a young man
he was a founder of the abolitionist
Society and he wrote fiery poems against
slavery and they burned his offices in
fill aver Eve Airy controversial bloody
wouldn't be silenced and the Quakers
wouldn't be silenced about their their
views against against slavery so this is
this is very familiar to me I liked when
I went to college and I certainly like
it like it here in fact there's a in our
main administration building there's a
quote from from John Greenleaf Whittier
that says early hath life's mighty
question thrilled with in the hearts of
youth with a deep and strong beseeching
what and where is truth and that's what
he'll still ask you know we want our our
students to get to know the professors
to make
friends that last forever and and we're
here in pursuit of truth what is what is
right what is what is moral what is true
so I'm really I'm really pleased to be
here now our first year we had a
mandatory semantics course we didn't
teach English we taught communications
and amazingly the gentleman who taught
our communications course also taught
Richard Nixon 30 years before he was a
young man for President Nixon a little
older for me and we devoted our entire
time to studying two great works of
literature okay one semester was devoted
to Moby Dick and and you know perhaps
the Great American Novel and it opens
call me Ishmael
right the other semester was devoted to
the study of Hamlet the greatest play by
the greatest English playwright and
Hamlet ends with a very very interesting
quote Hamlet's lost his girlfriend and
his kingdom and is now about to die
because of the treachery of his uncle
and he's dying in the arms of his best
friend Horatio and he says Oh God
Horatio what a wounded name things
standing thus unknown shall live behind
me if thou didst ever hold me in thy
heart absent thee from Felicity awhile
and in this harsh world draw thy breath
in pain to tell my story okay
I lived through Watergate beginning to
end for tonight
I am Horatio Ishmael I'm going to tell
you I'm the only survivor from the
inside everybody else has passed away
I'm gonna tell you the inside story of
Watergate in case there are any
snowflakes in the audience which I doubt
there's a trigger warning what I have to
tell you is not what you've been told
about Watergate okay
now the audience is kind of bifurcated
half of you remember what again you
probably watch the Ervin committee
hearings if everybody else did and watch
the administration go to pieces the
other half of you mainly the students
weren't even born so you know the word
but you don't really know what the
background is but don't let that trouble
you don't worry that you don't know much
about Watergate because everything these
other people know or think they know is
wrong it's wrong they've been they've
been told they they be incorrect stuff
in fact you might even think of it as
false news I mean wait you wait and see
you're wait and see why do I know how
can I stand up here and say I know
because I was there I was there
throughout I went from bucolic Whittier
which I really really adored to Harvard
Law School harsh cold demanding Alan
Dershowitz was my criminal law professor
given if you've seen the paper chase the
story of the first year at Harvard Law
School I was the kid who got wiped out
by the evil professor I mean this was a
real challenge but I survived I
graduated with honors and while I was
there while I was in law school dick
Nixon got elected president so I liked
him we were classmates well I had no
interest in government I I didn't want
to go to Washington what nothing worked
in Washington I was raised to believe
that the government was wrong you know
whatever it tried it messed up but since
this was an alum I decided I'd go help I
mean you know we're both from Whittier
and I applied for a White House
fellowship and I won so I got to go as
one of 15 young Americans to go to
Washington to study the executive branch
for a full year and I was 24 years old
right smack out of law school probably
one of the two or three youngest fellows
ever chosen and then
after that I was asked to join the
domestic council at the White House and
I spent five years there the domestic
council is the counterpart to the
National Security Council and it staffs
the President on domestic issues as
distinguished from Foreign Affairs so
and my focus was the Department of
Justice I was the policy guy for law and
order crime and drugs so I knew and I
worked with every single figure in the
Watergate scandal
these weren't names in the newspaper to
me I worked with some I liked some I
didn't like but I knew them all then
toward the end I was there five years
toward the end there was turnover we had
people leaving you know being arrested
being indicted yeah and so we brought in
a new team a new chief of staff
Alexander Haig a new lead Watergate
defense lawyer Fred Bussard and I became
a member of his defense team so for the
last year I was deputy to the lead
Watergate defense lawyer and in that
capacity I transcribed the White House
tapes
I ran the document rooms holding the
seized files and i briefed the senior
staff on Watergate developments now if
you've known or studied this or lived
through it you know it all ended rather
badly Nixon resigned in disgrace and two
dozen of my colleagues from the Nixon
administration were convicted and
imprisoned for various criminal offenses
but my role wasn't done because I ran
the document room and I produced under
subpoena documents that the special
prosecutor wanted I had to testify in
trial for them to be introduced so I was
a witness for the government in the
plumbers trial and subpoenaed to be a
witness in the Watergate cover-up trial
and I'm I'm on the wrong side say
because you know
so my friends but I I had to build built
it's called a Chain of Custody witness
how did that document get here the
lawyers enough to do that and then when
it was over when the long nightmare of
Watergate was over I was unemployable
because I'd work at the Nixon White
House and I went over to the special
prosecutor I said you know you know I
can't get a job and they say well you
know a lot of people got hurt in in
Watergate you you didn't do anything
wrong you didn't go to prison and and
son we don't write letters
we don't say you're cleared we indict
you or we're silent and I said you owe
me a letter
you owe me a letter I was a defense
lawyer I acted honorably and I can't get
a job and they did it okay the special
prosecutor wrote a letter the only
letter and it says in pertinent part he
said what do you want us to say I'll
tell you what I wanted to say after
checking with my task forces I can I can
tell you you have not you are not and
have never been the object of an
investigation of this office which is as
close as you get from the Nixon White
House to a certification of innocence
okay having cleared myself I ran away
left Washington DC moved my family to
Philadelphia it embarked upon a 30-year
career as a lawyer for the insurance
industry but it occurred to me right
after about 2004 that the people that
really knew what had happened inside the
White House not that not the reporters
and not the the people who who had gone
on or or been indicted and went through
the trials but stayed on the White House
staff they'd all died and that if I
didn't tell the story
nobody would so I decided I tell my
point of view it's not what everybody
thinks it's a it's a very very different
point of view but I discovered in doing
the the effort that the records of the
Watergate special prosecution force the
special prosecutor are kept at the
National Archive
they were government employees and those
records that have survived you can go
read this is like discovering 30 years
later that you can see the coach's
playbook from the team that defeated you
in the state finals you know what you
were trying to do now you can see what
they were trying to do and I think you
will be very interested in what I've
covered covered up now because of that
I've authored two books one book is in
20 2008 and it talks about the politics
behind the Watergate scandal and one is
was published in 2015 and it talks about
the prosecution's and how they worked so
we'll get to those things but first what
I want to do is do a quick comparison to
what's going on today I used to say in
these presentations you know there was a
ending of an election and undoing of an
election and if we don't recognize that
it could happen again well it might be
happening again so I don't know what's
going on today I don't want you to think
I haven't any inside information if you
keep up with it you'll be able to make
comparisons with what I can prove what's
going on 40 years ago
and you can wonder whether that same
thing is going on later later in our
nation so with that let's compare Nixon
to Trump as individuals there were eerie
similarities each is a changed candidate
prevailing in an exceptionally close
election in a hugely divisive era each
is a classic outsider thin-skinned and
distrusted by party elites each assumed
office opposed by every single DC based
institution Congress the hill staff the
federal bureaucracy the law firms that
think
tanks and especially the media and each
is furious perhaps understandably but
just furious about being bedeviled by a
highly partisan special prosecutor so
those are the similarities and they're
it's it's like as the opening said deja
vu all over again what are the
differences and they're considerable oh
so Nixon was a seasoned politician
lifelong Watergate clearly had crimes
there really was a break-in and there
really was a cover-up the Democrats in
the 1960s and 70s were firmly in control
of the Congress it was a two-thirds
one-third in both houses the Watergate
prosecutors back in the Nixon era had no
oversight by the Department of Justice
they operated with total and unreviewed
independence and in those days we called
it the liberal Eastern establishment and
their media controlled they controlled
all of the media there was no Fox News
there was no talk radio there was no
dissent there were three networks ABC
NBC and CBS they were headquartered
within six blocks of each other in
midtown Manhattan there were two
prominent newspapers the New York Times
in the Washington Post and there were
two prominent news magazines Time and
Newsweek and they all agreed so the
other point of view was never presented
we couldn't get our point of view out
and then finally I added this just
yesterday in retrospect Nixon played by
their rules played by the establishment
rules we have no assurance in today that
the current president is gonna is going
to behave like they'd like him to well
we'll see we'll see but you have a
random element in Trump he's not
going down easy okay let's go back to
1968 1968 and this is the 50th
anniversary of 1968 the nation was
tearing itself apart because of Vietnam
or the opposition to the yet no more
there were assassinations of Martin
Luther King and Robert Kennedy there
were bloody riots and demonstrations in
nineteen major cities and great
universities were brought to their knees
by student dissent on on lots and lots
of campuses across the nation it was a
hugely divisive era Nixon was elected on
to promises in the war peace with honor
and restore law and order we'll get
around to justice in a minute but first
we got to have we got to have domestic
tranquility we got to have law and order
and then he had an extraordinarily
successful first term his foreign
affairs victories are quite well-known
opening to China Soviet they taunt and
the strategic arms limitation talk
ending the war were the Paris Peace
Accords geopolitics in the Middle East
that removed Soviet influence and
substituted the US and saved Israel
during the Yom Kippur War I mean it was
a brilliant four years I didn't have
anything to deal with it because I
worked in the domestic side but his
domestic accomplishments were equally
impressive creation of eepa the clean
water clean air acts the Marine Mammal
act the anti ocean dumping act the
eighteen-year-old vote the peaceful
peaceful integration of southern schools
the ending of the draft the restoration
of rights to Native Americans the list
goes on and on and it was almost that
Nixon came into office and looked out
and said okay who's got a legitimate
complaint and he addressed them and we
call it today we didn't call it this
before we call it the pursuit of the
Justice Society because he tried to
address legitimate concern
he quadrupled the number of women
appointed to high government positions I
mean just the list goes on and so he's
re-elected in an absolute landslide
he carries 49 out of the 50 states he
only doesn't carry Massachusetts and the
district but there's this problem there
was this break-in back at the Democratic
National Committee headquarters and it's
lingering out there and that's what in
the end to the cover-up of that is what
brought him down so let's review very
quickly what happened in Watergate
there's this man named gordon Liddy
I worked with him you don't have the
pleasure of knowing gordon Liddy but I
do he was asked to develop a campaign
intelligence plan he did he prepared one
and it was reviewed at three meetings
with John Mitchell two of them occurred
in the AG's office and Liddy presented
this bizarre proposal for mugging
bugging kidnapping and prostitution and
I'm not making it up there were really
parts in there for that he got cut back
and in the end it didn't contain stuff
other than bugging the break-ins
occurred on May 28th and June 17th they
were caught red-handed on June 17th but
they were going back in there was a
trial and in the trial
everybody was convicted there were four
Cubans involved and there were three
people from the committee to re-elect
gordon Liddy Howard hunt and James
McCord and that was on January 30th 1973
before Judge John Sirica and Sarika was
not happy with the outcome because he
hadn't uncovered the responsibility for
who did this they were just the
prosecutors just said no we caught him
red-handed we don't have proof that we
can prove that they were involved but
the judge said no that's not good enough
I want a Senate investigation got it and
I'm going to give you a list of eight
people I want call I demand be called in
front of a grand jury because I think
they're responsible so the Senate Ervin
can
when you watched on TV was created in
February seventh and then things really
began to go south the cover-up collapsed
on sentencing day from the Watergate
burglary trial on March 23rd the special
prosecutor was appointed on May 25th
President Nixon resigned in disgrace on
August 9th and his top aides were
convicted on all counts in the cover-up
trial the cover-up truck came last and
they were convicted on New Year's Day
1975 and well the the the point I want
to make is the cover-up trial was the
capstone the end of the Watergate
scandal Nix is gone we didn't get him he
resigned but boy we got his aides and we
convicted him so there's no coming back
no second look at what we did in
Watergate so that's the those are the
dates they'll be on the exam for the
students you'll need to take these
things down what the trial came down to
and what the case was about was who was
responsible they these are the six key
players the row across the bottom are
the soldiers the people who got their
hands dirty who committed the crimes
gordon Liddy planned the intelligence
operation led to break-in his his boss
at the committee to re-elect was Jeb
Magruder Magruder sent him back in the
guter got the fruits of the wiretap and
the guy who hired gordon Liddy worked
with him on developing the campaign
intelligence plan had been present at
the meetings in the attorney general's
office when they were discussed was John
Dean John Dean's counsel to the
president but John Dean realized the
moment these guys were were arrested
that he was at risk of of being indicted
because he knew beforehand so he ran the
and he's admitted in public occasions
that he was chief desk officer for the
cover-up cover-up collapsed it should
have collapsed it was illegal the
question is were the people across the
top knowledgeable and responsible for
directing the cover-up there's a special
place in John's book where his lawyer
says you know John you got to talk to
these prosecutors and John says I don't
like them he says well they think you're
guilty John and unless you start talkin
conspiracy so you're a path to
higher-ups they're going to convict you
so John's story changes and we'll get to
it he comes in saying I can tell you who
was responsible for the break-in and
then he changes over the course of his
meetings with prosecutors to say though
those superiors the guys cost top row
they were directing me and of course
they are John Mitchell the Attorney
General Bob Haldeman Nixon's chief of
staff and John Ehrlichman my boss head
of the domestic Council the jury
believes John Dean they convicted the
top row of all counts and after the
smoke cleared on the cover-up those were
the only three others who were indicted
were separated out or reversed on appeal
or something else but when everything
was done these three guys conspiracy to
obstruct justice obstruction of justice
and perjury and their thing stood for 30
years until I came along and I
discovered documents that are terribly
terribly embarrassing so to summarize
what I think the Watergate special
prosecution force did we have the next
slide
they were as all special prosecutors
will hear more tomorrow they were a
specially recruited group of people the
people that were recruited all tended to
come from the Ivy League and their
leadership came from the kennedy johnson
department of justice
they met secretly with judges gizelle
and Sarika to work things out in advance
of trial I can show you a dozen meetings
where they met secretly you don't have
to be a lawyer to realize that's a no-no
you can't do that you can't go sidle off
in the corner with the judge but they
did they indicted Republicans on
relatively flimsy evidence but ignored
Democrats on hugely difficult or
challenging evidence in the end though
the records are there too to find them
they withheld exculpatory information
the government when the prosecution it's
not you win in any cost if they come
across evidence that tends to help the
defense they have to turn it over it's
called the brady rule but these
prosecutors didn't do that i'm going to
show you some evidence that they
declined to turn over and finally and
perhaps the most outrageous of all they
met secretly with the chief judge of the
appellate court to tell him how to stack
the deck on appeal so there was no
chance of being reversed
judge Sirico well he was chief judge was
the most reverse judge in the DC area
and he was reversed mainly for ignoring
the rights of defendants so the big
worry because he was so Pro prosecution
they would win at trial but would be
reversed on appeal that they fixed that
- by making a secret call on the chief
judge okay here you have a picture these
are the the members of the Watergate
special prosecution force his pictures
taken on the courthouse steps there's a
hundred people in this picture and what
you have to appreciate is from the first
day the table of organization the
intended role for the special prosecutor
was a hundred people they set out to
investigate every single aspect of the
Nixon presidency they announced at their
first press conference that they would
investigate everything not not just
Watergate everything about the Nixon
administration so we weren't told this
they've started dribbling out
tires and they stopped announcing them
but in fact it was a hundred people
there could be a hundred people that
decided they didn't like Hillsdale and
you wouldn't know where to protect
yourself this is like having a hundred
mothers-in-law that don't like you then
oh that one let me see your love letters
from high school no we're gonna get you
okay this next slide is a chart this is
a chart of the kennedy johnson
department of justice this is the
department of justice
that was removed from office when dick
Nixon was elected in 1968 I know you
can't read the names don't worry the
students the names are on the exam so
you you know get a hold of the slide if
they're shown in red and there are 17
names shown in red those were the top 17
lawyers in the Watergate special
prosecution force what they assembled
was the old Department of Justice that
was removed in because of the election
that was now in charge of unlimited
investigations of the Nixon
administration strange so what did they
do this is the political side of what
the special prosecution force did they
postponed their investigations of
Watergate Watergate was solved that's
why that's why people had to resign
that's why Elliot Richardson was brought
in as the new Attorney General that case
was already made by the career
prosecutors but what the Watergate
special prosecution force did this
political force recruited to get Nixon
they launched partisan investigations
designed to destroy the Nixon presidency
they set out to [ __ ] the Republicans
financial advantage Republicans used to
have far more money for elections they
sent IRS agents and FBI agents to
interview 150 major Republican donors to
an election that was held in 1970
nothing to do with Watergate well I've
got to tell you if you
were a major donor and the FBI came to
say well tell us about that buddy where
did that come from you wouldn't be so
eager to give money next time around and
they effectively stop to the Republican
advantage on money and then they
investigated and there are files that
prove this every single potential
presidential nominee from the from the
Republican side for 1976 I'm going to
give you a couple of examples Jerry Ford
is the first guy to become vice
president without an election so he had
to be confirmed by both the house in the
Senate and there was the most exhaustive
FBI background check of any individual
because he was going to become vice
president he might become president the
Watergate special prosecution force got
a copy of that and any questionable
thing that was raised about Jerry Ford
got leaked Jerry Ford when he became
president picked Nelson Rockefeller as
his vice president mr. clean and nothing
do with Watergate the Watergate special
prosecution force immediately launches
an investigation of Nelson Rockefeller
and it's in the records and the
allegation was Nelson may may have given
some money to McGovern to help McGovern
become the Democratic nominee happens he
may or may not have done it but in the
record that's shown awakened people up
at midnight to go get them to open a
safety deposit box where these records
might exist then if you recall history
Jerry Ford decided not to run in 76 with
Nelson he substituted instead Bob Dole
sure enough the Watergate special
prosecution force launches an
investigation of Bob Dole and it leaked
there was there was rumors about the use
of campaign funds and there's a very
bitter letter in the files where Bob's
lost Bob and you may not know this but
for lost in 76 to Jimmy Carter and Bob
Dole writes after that to the spell
prosecution force saying can I have my
records back now because you've seized
all my campaign finance records since I
was in public office and then finally
they investigated to Ronald Reagan them
okay Reagan is Governor of California
wherever California is 3,000 miles away
from Washington and there's a memo
there's not a file on it because they
destroyed the file there's a memo where
the guy is explaining to Jaworski what
they think they may get on Ronald Reagan
you talk about abuse of power you know
the Lord Acton was right power corrupts
and that record in these files shows
what kind of corruption occurred within
the special prosecutor's office now we
complained you may recall Trump
complains and says look these guys are
all political this isn't a fair
investigation
so the prosecute the Watergate special
prosecution force sends a public letter
this is now we're all professionals
nobody hears out to get you this is all
on the up and up worry none you know
we're lawyers and I came across a memo I
came across a memo in their file
confidential memo from Leon Jaworski to
his deputy that contradicts that this is
fun OOP there we go this is this is
Jaworski's memo to his deputy and I've
pulled it out of out of but it's a full
quote let me address myself to the
general tenor of your memo which
reflects an attitude I've discussed with
you before the subjective conviction and
that the President must be reached at
all cost
now Nixon can't be indicted he's the
sitting president they're supposed to be
after crimes and not people but the
whole hundred-man staff under person
staff is aiming for Nixon they're going
to get Nixon at all cost and then down a
little bit further he says it's not even
worth meeting with you people because
you work at this is his own staff you
works
before you come to see me so in its in
red at the very bottom it's too late to
get objective opinions from you I'm
gonna have to make these decisions on my
own you can't make this stuff up this is
a memo to his own staff saying I can't
work with you you're too biased of
course we didn't see this memo during
Watergate
so our Constitution is built on the idea
that you get a fair trial most Americans
would agree no matter how heinous the
crime no matter how despicable the
defendant you get a fair trial didn't we
hang you but you get a fair trial what
are the elements from the fifth and
sixth amendments that we might discuss
today well you get a fair and objective
judge you can't have a judge who's
sitting with a prosecution you get
prosecution that's nonpartisan that is
following the same rules they apply in
other cases you promised a jury trial a
jury of your peers that's untainted and
unbiased and you get an automatic right
of appeal in the federal courts
automatic right to the appellate level
none of these conditions prevailed in
Watergate none of them prevailed in what
again I'm going to show you some
examples in the center of my bull's eye
as the picture of John Sirica he's
appointed himself to be the trial judge
of both the burglary trial and then the
later cover-up trial around the clock or
the people he met secretly with to work
things out Leon Jaworski we've got a lot
of examples of that going clockwise
Edward Bennett Williams is the lead
lawyer for the Democratic side a great
trial lawyer now they'll tell you that
Sarika was appointed by Eisenhower so
how could you complain but Edward
Bennett Williams is his career mentor
they are so close that that he's named
Edward Bennett Williams and his wife as
godparents of his daughter they meet all
the time down at the bottom is a guy
named Clark Mullen off you don't know
the name he's the lead Washington
order back in that era who it just hates
Richard Nixon and he brags in his book
about meetings several times with Sarika
and convincing Sarika to use the trial
as a search for truth and then he says
of course I wrote supportive articles
news articles about this bottom Azurill
silver girl silver does one only is the
original career prosecutor he's a great
guy he's here because Sarika sought him
out to instruct him on house erectus
ought he should present the case very
odd for a judge to do that Archibald Cox
the original special prosecutor met with
Sarika we don't know what was said but
two times the press reports it Sam - was
chief counsel of the Ervin committee he
would go down and talk with Cerreta why
not they they were teachers at
Georgetown I was in a panel at North
Carolina last fall and one of the people
that the top aide for senator Ervin said
he was on the panel and he said you know
Sam - went down and saw Sarika all the
time he invited me to come along and I
see we shouldn't do that he said ah
don't matter III got stuff I want to
tell him and then and then finally Leon
Jaworski and we'll get a little bit more
- Leon this is not how trials are
conducted so here are three memos
they're difficult for you to read the
point is I got the memos okay it's not
just surprising these people met
secretly with a judge they made records
of their decisions so this is a letter
written in late December from Jaworski
to Sarika and we're only concerned with
the opening sentence when Messrs ruth
lockvar abend venus t and i met with you
in judge Gesell at your request on
Friday December 14th roll that one
around in your mind for a little bit the
four top prosecutors go meet with the
two judges that are going to try the
Watergate cases it doesn't matter what
they discuss because we don't know
there's no record of that but I can tell
you this three days before this meeting
Sarika had given the prosecutors the key
tape [ __ ] Watergate tape what John Dean
is called the cancer on the presidency
meeting where Dean comes in and tells
the president oh by the way there's
Vince Vince
perjury there's been a cover-up and they
turned that he turned that tape over
three days beforehand you read the books
written by the special prosecutors and
they described how appalled they were at
this tape so in my mind I have no proof
in my mind that's what they were talking
about they were talking about what what
this tape man oh and and the tapes
significance all I can prove is they met
but there is no occasion no way
no explanation for for prosecutors to
sit down with two judges next memo is
again from Leon Jaworski is confidential
Watergate file and it's a memo to the
file that memorializes his most recent
meeting with Judge Sirica I read on
Monday February 11th I met with a judge
at which time several matters were
covered as we sat alone in the jury room
he again indicated provided the
indictments came down in time he would
take the Watergate case he expressed the
opinion these indictments should be
returned as soon as possible well no
kidding
Judge Sirica is about to turn 70 years
of age he has to step down as chief
judge can't appoint himself he needs
those indictments to come before March
19th and they make it by three weeks
it's really tight and it's a deal
between the prosecutor and the judge
they'll bring the indictment in a timely
way so the judge can appoint himself to
preside over the trial last memo from
for today this is another confidential
memo March 1st is the date of the
indictment Jaworski goes into Sara's
chambers before the indictment before
the hearing to rehearse how they're
going to handle this and what Jaworski
says is I told the judge I would move
for special handling of this case
because that enables
the judge to take it out of the rotation
the random assignment of a judge because
the prosecutor said would this need
special handling
Sarika can appoint himself what she does
later that day and then they meet after
the indictments have been handed down to
talk about what else they need to cover
this is incredible now this stuff was
was covered up for 40 years this stuff
just came out within the last couple of
years because Leon Jaworski took his
files with him when he left office took
them back to Texas finished his career
gave them to his alma mater give your
papers dear alma mater and then the alma
mater took its sweet time making them
available so we couldn't have known this
in a timely way there's a completely
separate set of papers from another
prosecutor who went back to Harvard same
situation Harvard just open those papers
after my book was published and they
record the same thing Jaworski would
come back from his meetings with Sarika
and tell the senior staff what they'd
agreed to okay we got to change topics
for a second these are two examples of
what's called exculpatory evidence
remember the prosecutor must turn over
exculpatory evidence to the defense and
what we have are indications that John
Dean changed his testimony came in
saying I can give you the burglars and
who supervised the burglary changed to
there was a conspiracy I just did what I
was told here's the first example
these are handwritten notes that the two
new prosecutors took in interviews with
the original prosecutors dean has been
Dino's lawyer has been meeting with the
original prosecutors over the month of
April they meet her they talk on the
phone
12 times so these are the notes the
exact quote first of all when they're
talking about money Dean said yes they
were paying money to hunt but he never
said it was to buy hunt silence but the
best one is the next paragraph may
second and third situations in flux
because of the Senate committee
Hancock's dean becomes antagonistic to
Ehrlichman and Haldeman whereas before
he had given the impression that
Haldeman was clean and was restrained as
to ease involvement now when he comes in
in the beginning he doesn't even mention
them you know Haldeman's clean
ehrlichman's hardly involved but then it
evolves into I was doing what they told
me to do this had to be turned over but
it wasn't with regard to President Nixon
on May 3rd Dean became focusing on
President Nixon he he retains criminal
counsel at the beginning of April he
resigns at the end of April this is this
is two or three days after he's resigned
Dean began focusing on presidential
involvement thus dramatically changing
his previous stance
you couldn't draft a clearer memo that
had to be turned over to the defense
imagine if you're cross-examining John
Dean John is the principal government
witness well this is what you said then
and this is what you're testifying to
today were you lying then or are you
lying now that matter but Dean's
credibility is shattered okay third
topic game was the lead government
witness the only path to the senior guys
was through John Dean they needed him
and they needed him to be credible but
he's not particularly credible cuz he
ran the cover-up he didn't just obstruct
justice that if you look at the
documents he rehearsed Jeb Magruder for
his perjured testimony we call that
subordination of perjury he took four
thousand dollars of campaign funds for
his honeymoon
we call that embezzlement he took
materials taken from Howard hunts safe
and didn't give them to the FBI put them
in his file cabinet and later destroyed
them we call that destruction of
evidence and he took prosecutorial
information that he got from the
prosecutors and he shared it with
defense counsel that really is
obstruction of justice
so John Dean is at the very heart of the
wrongdoing and their worry was he
wouldn't make a credible witness so what
did they do they decided to sentence him
to prison in advance of the trial and to
throw the book at him
so they sentenced him to one to four
years in prison the harshest sentence
handed down to that date with his
incarceration to begin on the first day
of trial so he can testify that he's
been punished his life is ruined
he was these guys were in it you ought
to convict them so what does Sarika say
about that in his book I knew that what
Dean said on the witness stand wasn't
gonna make any difference in the
sentence I handed down so to prevent the
suggestion that he was testifying in the
hope I would reduce his sentence I
decided to give Dean that sentence well
before the trial this is contrary to
what usually happens in major cases what
did the prosecutors say about this in
their book moral balancing aside the
real politic of the situation was that
Dean wouldn't be an effective witness at
trial if he got a free ride the evident
effect of Dean's prison sentence later
on the jurors confirmed our tactical
judgment as the man who was already
serving a long jail term Dean made a
measurably greater impression than if he
had never been charged or punished for
his acts okay boy did we make him
credible one to four years incarceration
begins the first day of trial people are
all convicted one week after the jury
verdict that convicted everybody judge
Sirica reduces John Dean's sentence to
time served and he set scot free no
probation no parole
no nothing nice to have met you so he
goes from the most punished 1 to 4 years
to the least punished for months
then it turns out he never spent a
single night in jail never he was put in
a witness holding facility at Fort
Holabird Maryland so he spent his nights
in what amounts to army barracks where
he got conjugal visits from his wife and
in the daytime he was driven down to his
dedicated office with a special
prosecutors where he worked on his book
and John Dean recently has bragged on
three different radio shows pretty tough
don't you think but the American public
and the jurors who are convinced this
guy was being properly punished it was
it was a fraud engaged in by the judge
and the prosecutors and of course my
good friend John D so what do the
prosecutors do to Nixon's aides were on
the downhill side we're okay what did
the prosecutors do to Nixon's aides well
the fix was in they made in secret with
the judge work out issues and procedures
in advance of trial the dice were loaded
they worked they worked a deal with a
judge to assure the case was tried
before a DC jury they this is a I
digress you all did a survey of the
students on 2016 who who'd you vote for
and and the way I read it forty-nine
percent admitted they voted for Trump a
whole bunch of people either said they
didn't vote or they declined to state
and four percent said they voted for
Hillary okay so if Hillary were to be
brought out here and be accused of
something and the students were on the
jury
you wouldn't think she'd stand a chance
okay
but the the the the vote in in the D in
the district in 2016 was of course
exactly the reverse Hillary got 90% of
the vote there were some third party
candidates Trump got 4% those poor
people who are being investigated
if they come to trial in the D in the
District of Columbia where the jury is
drawn from the
fool of registered voters they don't
stand a chance and the same thing
happened with Nixon's people they were
tried in the District of Columbia after
52,000 column inches of adverse
publicity and a bunch of jurors who were
were diehard diehard Democrats and
finally the deck was stacked the special
prosecutor made in sync with the chief
judge to show how liberal control could
be maintained on appeal last slide and I
hate to leave you with this but I
decided I just did this this afternoon
these are the two great myths what did
they do to dick Nixon I've told you
about how unfair the trials were to
Watergate myths and I'm gonna leave you
cuz I can't convince you in the time
I've been allotted it's unfair myth
number one the June 23rd tape which is
called The Smoking Gun has been
misinterpreted for 40 years it seemed to
suggest that Nixon wanted the CIA to
tell the FBI not to interview two
witnesses because he was trying to stop
the Watergate investigation I thought so
too at the time this is what triggered
Nixon's resignation but it turns out the
purpose of getting the CIA to tell the
FAI not to interview these two people we
know who they are was because they had
channeled major contributions from
prominent Democrats who were playing
both sides and they didn't want to
embarrass those two Democrats you could
say that's a technical obstruction of
justice but there's no criminal intent
and so the reason Nixon resigned which
member came out right on August 5th and
then he resigned on August 9th the
smoking gun is simply misunderstood so
why how did the special
prosecutors get Nixon to be named an
unindicted co-conspirator backed by the
grand jury how did the House Judiciary
Committee decide Nixon needed to vote to
recommend Nixon be impeached that's the
second myth the tape of March 21st this
is when John Dean comes in and says you
know there's a cancer on the presidency
Howard hunt is blackmailing us he's
asked for money before Friday because
he's going to go off to jail and and and
you're gonna have to make the decision
and you need to know what's been going
on because you don't know what's been
going on so the member Howard Baker's
question what did the president know and
when did he know it the real question is
what did the president do and when did
he do it when he learned about the
cover-up and both Nixon and Dean have
maintained that he didn't get squiggly
that that's when Dean first told him
about the cover-up so our whole battle
our whole effort by the Watergate
defense team was what Nixon did on March
20 on and after March 21st and what I
discovered year two ago the prosecutors
concluded that Nixon had authorized the
payment of blackmail to Howard hunt no
witness ever said that but
circumstantially they concluded that was
true and they told the grand jurors so
they named him a co-conspirator I mean
he's personally approved the payment of
blackmail and they told the chief
counsel of the House Judiciary Committee
now they did both in private okay so we
didn't know they were making that bad
allegation against President Nixon and
I'm telling you if we knew we could have
refuted it but Nixon would never have
resigned Nixon knew he didn't order a
payoff of blackmail money and and things
would have unfolded differently but they
operated in secret
see and then of course they couldn't
prove it turns out that they were wrong
but after Nixon resigned and The Smoking
Gun came out they didn't care it's just
we just moved on and no one could call
the prosecutor on that what did Nixon do
and then I was stopped we'll take
questions I've limited you as much as I
can
what did Nixon do when Dean told him
there was a cover-up and if you listened
to the tapes and believe me I have
listened and transcribed and studied and
worried he tells his staff just beating
occurs in the morning he tells his staff
that afternoon Haldeman Ehrlichman Dean
and they're bringing Mitchell down the
next day that the way to beat hunt is to
disclose the information ourselves
that's how we beat the blackmailer
because he'll never go away so the next
day very next day Mitchell comes down
and Nixon tells his best friend that
he's going to call for a new
investigation new information has come
to my attention and I'm waiving
executive privilege and my staff will
come testify now you're sitting here and
if you if you know Watergate you're
saying can't be that's a hundred and
eighty degree off what we've been told
but it's true it's true thank you it's
been a pleasure talking to you
Thank You mr. Shepherd has agreed to
sign copies of his book the real
Watergate scandal immediately following
the lecture in the Searle Lobby we now
have time for a few questions please
raise your hand and wait for a
microphone to be brought to you
hi my name is Samuel I'm a junior here
at Hillsdale one name you never
mentioned is Charles Colson so I was
wondering if in these new discoveries
you discovered any evidence that would
incriminate him in any way yeah I knew
Chuck I didn't like him he was part of
the the dark side the campaign tricks
and that sort of thing I was a policy
wonk but he is offices right across the
hall from me of all of the Watergate
defendants Chuck got shafted the worst
he he was very prominent in his defense
of Richard Nixon he famously said I'd
Drive over my grandmother if it would
help Nixon get reelected but he wasn't
that involved in the cover-up so in the
in the internal review of who were going
to indict they have a big meeting and I
got the notes from the meeting and the
Watergate task force comes in and they
recommend we indict this indict this
indict this and they get to Colson and
they say well what's the likelihood of
conviction and I say what's fifty-fifty
he's really a marginal candidate now the
standard for the Department of Justice
is you've got to have a high degree of
confidence you can secure a conviction
from a jury that knows everything you
know so Jaworski says in one set of
notes I'm familiar with the facts I've
met with Chuck I've met with his lawyer
he's too scared he's gonna plead any way
he's going to come in and work out a
deal so we'll never have to prove it and
in the other set of notes he says and
this is James vorn Berger the associate
prosecutor he says Jaworski says I'd
really like to nail Colson she have a
guy who shouldn't have been indicted
this is so important that one of the
people in the meeting wrote a memo the
next day and said we can't do this you
understand mr. Jaworski every other
senior person in that room not the task
force but the reviewing force doesn't
think he should be indicted and this is
a violation of
justice guidelines that we said we would
adhere to okay now all copies of that
memo were destroyed one one surfaced I
got the memo it's in the book
so and I you know Chuck founded prison
fellowships you could say well and the
greater good greater number did it Chuck
devoted his life to it I wrote him a
letter 12 years after he got found a
prison fellowship and I said you know
Chuck I thought this was a con when he
first started but you've stuck with it
and here's some money cuz I'm I'm
embarrassed and I got a note back he
said Jeff you're not the only one that
doubted my sincerity but he spent the
whole rest of his life with with prison
fellowship next question so you have
time for one last question
fast-forward 50 years our Woodward and
Bernstein trying to become relative and
again or what's their deal there their
deal is they never named sources and
they make the most outrageous
accusations and people in Washington
know if they don't talk to them they're
going to get trashed in their book so
the lead career prosecutor Earl silver
one of the unsung heroes of Watergate
has said that not a single article that
they wrote helped the government because
what they were leaking was information
from mark felt the Deputy Director of
the FBI Woodward and Bernstein were
printing what the government already
knew and was investigating we didn't
know it but the prosecutors knew it you
can ask yourself what kind of
investigation is someone who gets a
government employee to leak what the
government knows and then prints this as
some kind of earth-shattering discovery
they're there they've had a wonderful
ride but they don't deserve it
iiiiii deliberately took all the time so
we got had no questions
thank you
[Applause]